who is satoshi nakamoto do you think and
first of all is it you
it definitely is not me
um i don't know who it is if it was
would you tell me
that's a trick question i know great
question but i mean everybody who knows
me knows i can't really code so
uh you would say that even if you could
but that's true do you think it's one
person do you think it's multiple people
is it interesting to you do you think
it's fundamental to the coin itself to
not the coin the
the entirety of the concept
um that its founders and animus and how
much guts do you think it takes if it's
one person just walk away from so much
money
i've considered all these questions many
times it's very hard to formulate
a definitive answer to all of them
i don't know who it is and i don't know
um
why
he or them or she
are not spending the coins that they
most likely have
i think what really matters
in bitcoin about satoshi is the fact
that he's not there
and this is what's truly astonishing
about it the fact the most important
fact in bitcoin is the fact that the
creators disappeared and the thing has
continued to operate now for almost 12
years without him being there or 11
years i think it's been since he's left
and this this is really the most
important thing and you know maybe maybe
he died or she died or they you know
they got into an accident on a
road trip or whatever and that's why
they haven't accessed their coins maybe
they're incapacitated for some reason
but whatever reason it is i really think
it's
fate or serendipity that is uh given us
this very vital
very very very vital building ingredient
in bitcoin which
no other digital currency would ever
recreate which is that
you know because it was the first
it was the one that was able to um
establish the first mover advantage and
get all the people who are interested in
the technology to get into it
and so that's an enormous advantage but
you know the the the
cherry on top or what made the whole
thing really function well is the fact
that the guy who made it disappeared
and that it continued to operate which
is just a clear illustration that this
is a network with no admins
and i'm tempted to think that they're
incapacitated in some way probably dead
or gone because i
i can't believe
the
i don't believe any human being would
have this
level of self-control to not
get into not want to meddle with their
invention uh so much um even even even
if they you know they might have had the
self-control to like mine the first
million coins to get the network going
and then throw away the coins on or send
them to an address that they don't have
the key to
because they really just wanted the
network to take off they may have no
access to the coins and that's why they
can't move them i could see that
happening but i find it harder to
believe that they would resist the
temptation to mess with the network you
know it's funny i find that the founders
of ideas are often
principled and have the integrity
that the eventual users of those ideas
uh don't fully have
i i tend to you know we have the kind of
cynical view power corrupts absolute
power corrupts absolutely and we tend to
in our mind generalize that all humans
are corruptable
and perhaps that's true to some degree
but i think some people are more
corruptable than others and i find that
there is i mean this i like to think
that uh satoshi nakamoto is out there
and uh you know just like george
washington chose to walk away and it's a
principle and the principle is more
powerful than
the financial reward or any of those
kinds of things um
it's a principle that stands for freedom
and there's a lot of people throughout
history even recent history that are
willing to die for these principles
or live a life
full of suffering and sacrifice because
they're still living a life
of principle and choosing that day after
day after day so um i mean there's power
to that money what's what's the worth of
money in the end
uh in terms of just personal financial
gain
versus
um
knowing how much positive impact there
is
so the person that chooses to walk away
like that i think is the same kind of
person that chooses to live
um
live by that principle you have you have
people like that you know in
uh gregory gaisha pearlman in
mathematics who turned down the fields
medal
because he was
yeah that's the medal not 50 billion
dollars of bitcoin well that's i i know
i know i'm joking well that's actually
an interesting just a brief comment you
know when people talk about bitcoin in
the cryptocurrency space
it's often mixed up
financial interest
and
ideas
and i think there's often correlated
but
that good feeling you get when you win
or you um number go up or you just
just somebody you know i found 20 bucks
on the street the other day
and just that feeling of just like
like more money
that positive feeling that's correlated
but it's it is distinct from the power
of the idea to change a world uh to
change the world for the better for the
to alleviate it's like alex gladstein in
the case of bitcoin that decreased the
amount of suffering in the world because
of the authoritarian regimes and just
because your your number goes up like
that gambling feeling of like yes yes
this is good uh and i'm i mean
short-term
numbers go up there's a long-term i'll
go up that's more like investment and so
on and there's a short time that will go
up it's just a good feeling that you
can't you have to in your mind keep
those distinct from um
from the power of the idea to transform
the world and if you focus on the power
of the idea
a billion or billions of dollars don't
matter as much
at least that's what i would like to
believe perhaps but what matters
ultimately is that the thing works
without him the things worked for 11
years without him and i think this is
this is the really important thing if
they had stuck around for whatever
reason and they had continued to meddle
with it
it's not clear to me how decentralized
it could have been
this is the problem with the other
currencies it's like how do you
lose control of the frankenstein that
you've created the only way that this
frankenstein continues to survive is if
the person in charge of it continues to
feed it
and so
it continues to be yours and that's
that's the problem with all the other
digital currencies if you've heard about
any of the other 16 000 digital
currencies out there
you've only heard about it because
there's a small group of people behind
it that are working on it that are
promoting it
and that's why and i think you know
michael seda's discussion with you was a
magnificent illustration of
the difference between bitcoin and alt
coins in that they are securities and i
think he makes a very compelling
brilliant case for
why this is uh makes them categorically
different from bitcoin bit when you're
buying property
i think he mentioned he's a huge fan of
dogecoin but i might be misremembering
you are misremembering okay i need to
maybe i'm quoting him out of context
you